[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and tonight i am both your driver
on this journey and the master lab 2
champion
we just had a small invitational
tournament here at the chess club called
the master lab it's the second edition
and i was fortunate enough to walk away
the champion this time so tonight i want
to show you a few of my games from that
event and uh these games are going to
focus on a theme so
these games basically went in three very
very different directions but i felt
that they all had some stuff in common
so
we're gonna look at what happens when
a slightly uh lower rated player than
myself makes some weaknesses or some
mistakes early in the game and we're
going to see the different ways that the
game's developed from there so to start
with i want to show actually my final
game against pratik namali who i think
is around 2000 uscf
but uh due to some really good
performances in his first v-day
tournaments speeder rating is actually
like 21.99 at the start of the
tournament so
kind of unclear how strong he is exactly
uh for sure he's he's a young guy he's
going to be doing things with chess uh
regardless
uh but in this tenth round uh pratik
played this move e4 against me we got
into a keracon he exchanges on d5
uh and plays this move knight f3 right
away so you can definitely play like
this with white it's not going to cause
you any problems to play like this but i
do think that this move order
does let black off the hook just a
little bit so does anybody know um a
couple of the two different ways that
white generally plays these positions
what is white normally doing here
yeah so c4 is the pan of attack and that
is you know kind of the more aggressive
way to play you go after this d5 pawn in
the center things are going to open up
really early on and white's going to try
to kind of kill you in the opening
but there's another very well accepted
way to play uh foreign advantage with
white here one that takes a lot less
risk
yep that's exactly right you go bishop
d3
in c3
and here does anybody know the move
it's not this one if you're really
really fighting for the advantage so
what else can you do and and why is it
better than knight f3
what's the point of playing bishop d3
and c3 rather than the knight f3
yeah queen c2 might be okay but actually
i i like the queen here for the moment
instead we're going to develop this
bishop with bishop f4 and the reason why
this is better than playing something
like knight f3 is it puts a really
awkward question to black and that
question is what are we going to do with
this light squared bishop
because we would love to develop it
outside our pawn chain before we play
the move e6 but due to the very specific
move order that white has played we got
bishop g4 here queen b3 is going to be a
very serious try for an advantage and
now white does not have to worry about
any bishop takes f3 sort of shenanigans
so that's why i think if you want to
play the way that pratik is playing it's
a little bit better to go for this other
move order instead
but in the game he goes knight f3 not a
big mistake by any means it just makes
my life a little bit easier i develop my
knight he plays c3 i play bishop g4 and
now i don't have to worry as much about
these queen b3 ideas because i i can
always chop on on f3 and have a pleasant
position
so bishop d3 in the game both sides are
just going to finish development bishop
f4
i'm not really afraid of trading off
these bishops
kingside castles knight f6 rookie 1
castles
h3 was inserted
i
do not really want to give up my bishop
for this knight just yet so i come
bishop f5
and knight b to d2
so let's just take stock of what's going
on so far
does anybody recognize this pawn
structure of course it's the carl's
badge structure uh and so
with that in mind we already have some
idea of what some some common plans are
so with black we have the e pawn in the
carl's badge structure i guess reversed
carlsbad if you want to be technical
uh so what are some common plans for for
black to play here
yeah uh the minority attack is probably
the first one you guys are gonna gonna
hear about so what is the minority
attack just very quickly if you're
unfamiliar
um that is when you use your pawn
minority in this case the a and the b
pawns to attack upon majority and try to
provoke some weaknesses and we're gonna
see a really great example of this plan
a little bit later tonight so i won't go
into too much more uh depth there
uh but what else can can black try to
play for here if not the minority attack
is there any other plan
yeah f6 e5 is also another way to play
and i this is what i normally try try to
play with the white pieces for example
when i get this structure with colors
reversed
um but outside of that
you know with with the black pieces here
we're more concerned with just making
sure we're surviving the opening opening
becoming fully equal and so what i
played in this position which maybe it's
not uh
the most accurate move is actually
bishop g6
and the thinking was this is white's
best minor piece if i can trade this off
then i don't really see a reason why i
should be much worse
so pratik agreed and agreed that he
should be trading and took on g6
not really worth it to try to save this
bishop
because once this bishop moves away now
my minor piece is very very strong and
your piece has lost a lot of its power
it's really just this d3 square that's
super annoying so bishop g6 he takes on
g6
it also would have been totally fine to
play something like knight f1 and allow
black to make the trade but rather than
uh
valuing this tempo to activate the queen
a little bit uh pretty valued messing up
my pawns just the slightest amount you
know doubling these pawns
making a little bit harder for me to
control some squares like g5 for example
the game continued with a4 so pratik was
very much anticipating a minority attack
and before i even hinted that i wanted
to play the move b5 he was sort of uh
aiming against it
so i just play simple chess bring my
rook to c8 it's a half open file i might
want to put a knight on c4 i still might
want to play for for a6 b5
uh batik plays queen to e2
so once again very much guarding against
the minority attack
i play a6
i don't know if i'm going to play b5
just yet but it's nice to have the
option
and then knight e5 and so then this is
where i want to sort of pause again and
take stock of what's going on
so we're playing with the black pieces
our main idea is to go for this minority
attack but white is pretty heavily
trying trying to stop us
our opponent has just put this knight
onto the e5 square it's going to be a
very strong square for for his piece and
uh we've organized our rooks sort of on
the queen's side you know aiming down
the c file zurich might want to stay
here if the a file opens up might want
to come to b8 to support b5 uh and now
i'm i need to sort of take some time
figure out what my opponent is trying to
do so thus far very normal opening moves
pratik is aiming against the queen's
side but what is he actively trying to
do how is he trying to uh put put some
pressure on me
see if you guys can come up with some
ideas
yeah
so in the game i knew that's uh
just from past experience i knew that
pratik was a big fan of this f4 game
plan so this is one thing to look out
for
but it's actually not the best way to to
play here with whites
so i was kind of hoping for for f4
what else could white uh try to do
and this is a plan that you guys might
have not seen before but it actually
turns out to be very very serious uh for
black to deal with
i'd consider the sack on g6
on to the third rank and then
not immediately but i'm saying set up
for it yeah
so uh considering some psycho stuff
taking on g6 at some point and trying to
go for a massive kingside attack
and that's sort of the the textbook plan
not necessarily you know
specific sacrifices
but in the carlsbad structure the side
with the the extra pawns on the queen
side it's actually somewhat
counter-intuitively trying to attack on
the king's side a lot of the time
um but it's important uh above sort of
all other things in the carlsbad to
remain sort of flexible
so in this case
um even small changes in the position
can can change your plan pretty
drastically so as black i'm trying to
stay flexible because i see how heavily
my opponent is trying to stop b5 so i'm
thinking of other ways to play
and similarly you know f4 or you know
vaguely attacking on the king's side
it's gonna be one way of playing but
it's actually possible
for white to sort of meet me on the
queen side and try to play on this side
of the board as well and that was the
plan i wanted to highlight here um
uh just just rather quickly so in the
game i play this move queen to c7 which
turns out to be a pretty good move
the reason being
i am trying to induce this move f4 now
we listed f4 as one of the moves that
white might want to play in you know
combination with trying some kind of
king side attack but i had some very
specific uh justifications here so
number one this structure is a little
bit different than this structure and
one big thing is it helps me control the
f5 square a lot more easily
so after a move like f4 i'm actually not
as concerned with f5 it's going to take
white some time to build up to this f5
move and this structure helps me play
play against that just a little bit uh
outside of that you know f4 i mention
this all the time comes with some pretty
major drawbacks so let's just list those
really quickly
why would white maybe not want to play
f4
yes so the one everybody loves to point
out right away is it weakens the
diagonal but in this case it's actually
not very relevant right this diagonal is
is pretty locked down so what else
weakens yep these two squares also these
two squares right because you can no
longer play f3 but even more importantly
than that um it actually makes my play
on the queen side stronger so how does
that make any sense how does f4 make the
queen side play stronger well the the
thing that often goes unmentioned is it
very much weakens the second rank and
indirectly the the king
so with the pawn on f2
just imagine a scenario where i'm
crashing through on the queen's side and
things are opening up
with the pawn on f2
it's a little bit easier to to keep
everything defended right you know one
day if
uh the g pawn gets attacked it can still
step to g3 king g2 your king has all
this nice little shelter with the pawn
on f2
with the pawn on f4 there's sort of not
not a lot in the way of of me coming
after this king and so it's a little bit
way down the road but f4 makes long-term
weaknesses and that's sort of what i was
hoping for
so what i think a better plan for white
is here is actually two different ideas
you can start with knight d to f3 i
think this makes a lot of sense and
you're not worried about the trade
you'll just replace it with the other
knight but i think actually knight to d3
could potentially be a very annoying
idea for for white in this position
and what's the point
well let's imagine i actually do achieve
this move b5 one day and let's put a
takes b actually let's not put a takes b
on the board um white actually has a
really annoying move here you can insert
a takes b if you want but that's not the
main idea
so knight to c5 is definitely connected
to the idea but white can make a change
in the structure that might be
unexpected but is actually very very
beneficial to white
so how can white change the structure
here
in his in his favor
which pawn
the a pawn okay so not quite i mean al
already concretely i think i can capture
so if he pushes the beep on then it uh
allows him to play c4 next
um so we do want to push the b-pawn but
not to b3 uh we're not really playing
for c4 we're actually playing for b4 i
think in this position and this is a
plan that can be very very dangerous for
black to deal with because first of all
white is kind of in control of when the
a file is going to open up that's why i
said you can insert it but you don't
really want to a lot of the time because
you can do this later
and beyond that we no longer have any
kind of minority attack first of all uh
white has voluntarily made a weakness
here on c3 but as uh tony mentioned out
here
tony mentioned here um it's not going to
matter because knight c5 is very
effective at stopping up this file and
by the way having a very very active
piece uh attacking a6 attacking e6 and
after getting this huge change in
structure on the queen slide
then maybe uh having secured the queen
side white can can start to get a little
bit more loose over here on the king's
side
so this is sort of how i thought the
game might go and again knight d to f3
trying some knight g5 stuff also uh
possible
but instead my opponent played sort of
the worst of all three worlds and played
g4 so
much like f4 g4 is very very weakening
but the idea i you know i thought was um
just not going to be as strong as well
not not as threatening to play stuff
like g4 compared to f4
so
immediately how do you take control of
the game here with black black isn't
like winning or anything but you can
very much take control
with the next few moves
great wolf in the chat has asked did i
fall out of my chair when g4 was on the
board
not really but i did like you know i did
lean forward i was very excited
very excited to see the move g4
what was that
okay this score is d5
e5 yeah knight takes e5 um if you met
knight to e4 this is sometimes a move
that we want to play uh but here just
concretely we don't have enough enough
defenders but yeah knight e5 this is now
a very favorable change in structure for
black
so white theoretically could just
capture with the queen but i'm not gonna
be unhappy about uh
first of all a queen trade second of all
maybe even just play knight to d7 here
and if the queen retreats uh look at all
these newly weakened squares because
this this g pawn has been moved um but
also not really unhappy with this
position either
um i'm not sure black is exactly
crushing it but this minority attack
plan once again is is gonna be on the
cards
um
so in the game my opponent took back
with the pawn trying to keep the
pressure up
so now
this is gonna be the common theme i
think in in the games that i show you
tonight so white has made some opening
mistakes and because of those opening
mistakes there are weaknesses sort of
littered throughout the board
uh and so in the three games you're
gonna see me trying to take advantage of
those weaknesses with varying degrees of
success and we're going to see
some good play by the quote-unquote
weaker player uh
we're going to see some bad play by the
weaker player and we're going to see
some bad play by everybody involved
sometimes so
in this game i think that pratik did not
do the best job of putting up the most
resistance so i wanted to start with
this sort of as an example of what not
to do if you find yourself in one of
these positions
um so starting from here i have to move
my knight so i play knight to d7
pretty continues out with h4 uh very
very aggressive
uh and now
i think the next few moves are very easy
for for black to come up with they're
very natural but they're also pretty
important so white is doing some scary
stuff over here but we have some really
nice tempo moves that bring all of our
pieces into the game so see if you can
find maybe a sequence of two to three
moves here that bring the rest of your
pieces in
how to activates
so what am i talking about
yeah yeah so i'm talking about you know
these pieces in particular right right
now they're sort of looking at a pawn
that's defended but using these
weaknesses across the board we can bring
them in so you said queen to g3 i think
you mean queen b6 right
yeah so we can definitely start with
this this allows the rook to breathe a
little bit and not only that it's a
tempo move we attack the pawn on b2 our
opponent has to respond uh he came up
with knight to f3
now how did you want to follow up so of
course knight f3 defends with the queen
yeah just rook to c4 we bring the rook
into the game also a tempo move so our
opponent plays knight to d4 trying to
stop up our play
i just play rook a to c8 now in the game
this one isn't a tempo move but now all
of a sudden
you know three moves later we've
activated our queen pressuring this
weakness we've activated our rooks with
pressure down the c file along with the
a4 pawn and even the g4 pawn
and white hasn't really advanced their
plans at all like the knight moved from
d2 to d4 which is an improvement but all
of our pieces are starting to sort of
come into the game
now pratik plays h5 which i think is is
good you know it's not
uh whenever you have weaknesses like
this you need to play actively go for
active counter play what you can't do is
what critique started doing doing after
this so i play g5 in the game trying to
keep things a little bit more closed
um
pratik plays a5 pushing my queen back to
d8
and then queen to e3
sorry then king to g2
um queen to e3 might happen next don't
worry about it
um
and so so far so good for petite i
actually like how he's he's been
handling things here so king to g2 does
anybody see the the sneaky idea with
with king to g2 what might white have in
mind
each one yeah white's probably going to
try to come after us here uh some rocket
h1 and h6 stuff so just just be aware
that that's going on now i don't think
black needs to go crazy and respond to
it right away instead we should look to
finish activating our pieces so
uh how how can we achieve that what's
the next piece that we need to activate
the knight should go to either e4 or f4
e4 is going to be a lot easier okay so
you're correct that we need to activate
the knight um and you're also correct
that these squares look great right
these squares look sort of amazing you
know if knight f4 were legal i would win
the game um
but you also have to be sort of
realistic with your plans here so knight
f4 not really going to be realistic
there's just actually no path to this
square on the board
um and now knight to e4 also has a
problem associated with it so what might
the problem be if we plan to bring our
knight to e4
yeah f3 is actually a very favorable
move for white here it defends the
weakness on g4 defends the e4 square and
so there's really no point in trying to
bring her knight to e4 if it's just
going to have to move away
so what else can we do with this night
how can we
how can we use it effectively
yeah that's exactly right um
it might sound weird to try to
effectively use the knight by trading it
for our opponent's knight but this
knight is really the only thing holding
white's position together right this
knight is
single-handedly stopping our rooks from
uh you know attacking or invading over
on the king's side it's defending all
these annoying squares um
in white's camp and it's it's just a
great piece so our knight you know
knight c5 might look tempting at first
because you know you're heading for
squares like e4 uh but in reality this
this knight just doesn't do anything on
c5 except maybe get your rook trapped um
immediately your rook's not trapped but
let's say white plays f3 in response
you don't have a second move right you
know your best move might be knight to
d7
so that's why knight to b8 actually
turns out to be the correct plan here
um white now plays queen to e3 and we're
going to follow through with knight to
c6
you do have to see one tactic here but
one tactic is enough so if white had
gone for something like this
black is of course winning because of
this fork on c2 so that's the only
tactic you need to see maybe in the
whole game
so instead white captures on c6 and i
take back with the rook
now it turns out that white has one way
and only one way to
maintain the balance here and it's a
very sort of unusual plan so i would be
very impressed if you guys could come up
with it but it turns out he should
continue playing consistently you know
no need to respond to me over here
because if you start responding and
defending then your weaknesses are just
going to sort of be the deciding factor
but instead rook to h1 would have been
nice
king to h7 is very natural
and we are just going to meet h6 with g6
and at first glance this might look a
little scary over here on the king's
side but the king turns out to be very
very safe the h-pawn is a nice shield
for us and white's not going to be able
to attack the king very easily
but it turns out there is a very nice
plan here for white that i think both of
us missed in the game would have been a
great plan for someone to find but a
very very unusual plan so if you guys
want to take just a second here
see if you can come up with a way for
white to play for the advantage
turns out black is still doing fine if i
play well but it does put the pressure
on
what's it do
all right this one's pretty tough nobody
in the chat's getting it either it's
actually rook h3
with the very specific idea of going
rook f3
with the very specific idea of going
rook f6 and then this pawn is hard to
defend
um
so if you saw this from afar then you're
a super genius and you're way better at
chess than me and critique but both of
us miss this idea in the game uh turns
out this it's just good
uh now
you know in fairness let's see what line
i had put uh what line i had here
um yeah after rook h1 knight takes d4 is
what black should do which makes a lot
of sense king h7 h6 g6 rook h3 turns out
black can even just play f5 here and
this is how the game would have
maintained a balance
and despite this being a little bit
scary this work end game turns out to be
drawn so that was the only way for white
to stay equal
instead after knight to c6 this position
does turn out to be just very nice for
black i played rook c6 in the game f3
king h7
rook to d1 and then i had this very very
uh nice repositioning where i go king to
h6 defending the pawn with my king
freeing my queen to join the attack
and now pratik continues doing exactly
what you shouldn't do if you have a lot
of weaknesses against a higher rate of
player
the last thing you want to do is curl up
into a ball and just hope that's you
know everything stays defended because
it never does in practical games you
know sometimes computers will hold
positions like this they will just curl
up into a ball defend their weaknesses
and then you know there's just no way to
break through but in human play
especially you know non-grand master
human play
uh it's just an impossible way to try to
play chess so what should critique have
done here i think he should have tried
to get active maybe play rook to d4
and
i don't know hope against hope that he
can invade somehow over here like rook
a3 rook b3 just try to get some counter
play or something even if it's not
supposed to work out
instead what he dis does is rook to d3
and after queen to c7 rook to a3
so what is pratik's idea pritik's idea
is that after rook to c5 attacking the
a5 pawn he's gonna go b4
and i guess his plan is to just leave
all these pieces here and hope that i i
can't break through so i think that this
is a very very easy way for the higher
rate of player or the player with the
advantage to just sort of play any move
that he wants like i can do really
anything i want in this position and i
know that i don't have to be worried
because my opponent's plan is to sit
there and do nothing just let me try and
try and try and then hope i can't break
through
so again
this game is the example i think of how
you shouldn't be playing when when you
have a bunch of weaknesses you have to
get active
you have to fight back you can't just
sort of sit back like this
um in the game i chose not to include
rook to c5 i think i could have but
instead i just go with rook f4
and then actually the the end came very
very quickly for pratik here he plays
this move king to g3 which at first
looks sort of uh
fine i mean it's it's a move you have to
play a move here with white you've
already set up your pieces on these
awful squares and sort of said you're
going to keep them there
but it does turn out this one loses to a
tactic which
it might seem like oh if only white
hadn't hung a tactic then he would have
stayed in the game but eventually
you're going to hang a tactic in these
positions you just can't play them
forever and ever and ever and and not
expect to to lose something in the end
uh but black to move and get a huge
advantage here how can we do it after
king to g3
yep so just f6 and we're just attacking
this pawn twice
and one of the weaknesses has has just
fallen of course you cannot take this
pawn because rookie four is going to be
checked
and attacks the queen
so f6 and now black is just winning
and
more mistakes happen later in the game
but those aren't quite as instructive
so the game ended like this i just break
through with e5 and e4 now
uh you can't actually take this pawn
because rook f2 is very very nice with
checkmating threats and then queen h2
when i'm threatening one two
three maybe four depending on how you
count uh four ways to checkmate
you can only defend like three of them
so the fourth one is gonna gonna end up
succeeding
um
so he didn't take instead he goes king
g3
we shuffled around a little bit and then
eventually uh pratik
allowed me to trade off all the pieces
go g6 and enter this winning king and
pawn end game
which was not so not so difficult
uh so this was the first game i wanted
to show because things really fell apart
in the space of like four or five moves
there for white and they fell apart as
soon as he like gave up on attacking me
gave up on being active he just said all
right i'm gonna curl up into a ball and
we'll see what happens so that is my big
example of of what not to do
and yeah james in the chat says nice
game very clean
yet there's a reason why i blew through
the latter half of that game mistakes
were made but don't worry about it um
the point is practically you cannot play
like this and expect to hold your
position for forever in in most cases
um so now i want to look at the
counterpart to this game which is my
game against uh another local kid by the
name of vinnie thready toddy party um so
vinnie as we call him is another young
chess playing kid in in st louis who is
climbing the raiding ladder and no doubt
will will be passing me before too long
but i've still got i think another year
or two on them where i can uh can keep
pressing
so vinnie had the white pieces against
me
and he chose to play this uh sort of
king's indian attack type setup
uh and i was ready for this you know
it's a invitational tournament i know my
opponents in advance i know what they
play and so i had prepared this line
with g6
so
this is how the theory normally goes
black goes e5 we get this nice central
pawn duo and in return white is going to
try to break down our central pawn duo
in any number of ways in the game he
chose knight to e2 which i wasn't quite
as familiar with the normal move is just
knight g to f3 here
but i figured this didn't change too
much i just go knight e7
supporting my center
probably i chose 97 for a very similar
reason why vinnie chose knight to e2
sometimes it's nice just to have this
bishop open it helps defend your pawn
and if this pawn ever moves then the
bishop can be very very active
um and the knight on f6 is not going to
be all that much better than the knight
on e7 the main point is we are helping
to defend
this pawn on d5 and in some instances
i'm going to be very happy to be
defending the f5 square as well maybe
one day white goes f4 f5 and i'm
defending it one more time with my
knight so king side castles for white
king side castles for black
white goes a4 which is a pretty common
move actually in these structures it's
anticipating
this change in structure that often
happens so let's say a5
something that will very commonly happen
in these structures is white goes b3 or
c3 one of the two black wants to go d4
and white will occasionally want to put
this knight onto c4 so the idea of going
a4 is to preempt some of these b5 ideas
and if black allows you let's say black
just plays like bishop b6 we're going to
be very happy to just even gain a little
bit more space with something like a5 in
these positions
so a4 played by vinnie not a bad move i
go a5
uh and then veni loses his mind um so he
takes on d5 which is already sort of
really really strange
um i guess his idea is to help open up
this bishop a little bit but i'm able to
take back and now i have two versus one
in the center you know opening
principles having control of the center
still a good thing
and then he goes c4 so he's entering the
sort of benoni style structures
and i guess he was hoping that i would
push d4 and then he would be able to
make good use of the e4 square of these
weakened light squares and this bishop
would be able to sort of wreak havoc you
know the normal benoni ideas
now there's a problem with this and that
problem is the benoni is not a very good
opening
um but there's another problem with this
and that's why
that's why the game sort of took a turn
for the worse for vinnie um i'm by by no
means obligated to play d4 here and in
fact i just don't you know i think it's
better to just develop my pieces so so i
do so
knight c3 by white bishop e6 by black
then he decides it's time to capture
and once again i want to pause for a
moment take stock so
white has made some pretty serious
opening mistakes here and is saddled
with himself with this permanent
weakness on d3 so not quite as many
weaknesses as the last game we looked at
but d3 is going to be weak a4 is sort of
weak it could be attacked and b2 is also
a pawn you definitely have to have to
keep an eye on with the bishop on g7
now instead of taking this other
approach where you can imagine very
easily white trying to do something like
uh here i'll just i'll play some bad
moves like rook rookie one
bishop f1
and let's say like rook a3 like really
just
super ultra trying to defend this pawn
over and over again like this would be
one way to play you just try to defend
this pawn try and you know prepare for
it for the oncoming assault
and uh just just play like this try and
keep your pawn defended as many times as
possible and try not to lose it uh but
this is only gonna make your position
worse so what you need to do when you
have a weakness like this is not sort of
sit back try and defend the pawn as many
times as you can but instead go for very
very active counter play so black's
position in this case is not perfect
either you know a4a5 being on the board
makes my pawns on the queen side just as
weak as my opponent's pawns
on top of that you know this bishop is
now on this wide open diagonal
so i really like how vinnie treated this
position even though he's already pretty
significantly worse he was able to find
active counter play and give himself
chances
so to start with he goes knight d to e4
so already
he's trying to keep the pressure up
against my queen's side
i come up with the move knight d to b4
so already you know i'm trying to target
the weakness trying to activate my
pieces
um vinnie immediately plays the move
knight to c5 so
not pausing for a moment to do anything
about the d-pawn instead he's combining
active play with defense you know
bringing the pieces forward continuing
to attack
i play bishop f5 a very desirable move
which does take advantage of a little
tactic here you cannot play knight to b7
uh because i think simply just queen to
d or queen to e7 is my idea and the
knight is trapped
can't get away with it just yet
so instead vinnie comes up with this
move knight to b5 notably again this
pawn on d3 is just hanging vinnie
doesn't care he says that pawn's weak
i'm coming after you i'm coming directly
after your queen slide
and sure you can take this pawn but i'm
going to take your pawn
and now with the addition of a second
knight i can come back with knight to d6
and you've got serious problems you've
got serious serious problems you're no
longer up uh you're not up upon my
weakness is now gone and my bishop is
still reigning supreme over the board
so again very active play by vinnie
keeping himself in the game so of course
you know i i'm going to be thinking as
well in the chess game so i don't take
on d3 uh and instead just play the
simple move queen to e7 you know he
threatened to take my pawn for real this
time so i'm going to defend it
vinnie again does not pause to
sort of meekly defend his position
activates another piece bishop to e3
of course i'm going to play rook f to d8
you know chess is simple sometimes you
just want to put all of your pieces
attacking the weakness uh activating
with tempo
uh and so what does vinnie do he plays
rook to a3
so rook to a3 in this instance i think
is just sort of required
yes it is a defensive move
but it's also a very activating move
right this rook is gonna have some
potential on these squares
it also steps off of you know
a long diagonal that might turn out to
be problematic for for white
and here i think i make no i don't make
a mistake i continue playing well for
another couple of moves at least uh i go
knight to d5 so targeting this opponent
my opponent's bishop trying to drive
back these pieces just a little bit
um queen to e2 by vinnie
i play rook a to c8 which does turn out
to be a little bit of a mistake turns
out i can play just more concretely here
i don't really remember the lines yeah
just knight c to b4 first uh sort of
transposing the knights
and then after
takes takes
i'm just going to have the nice bishop
pair here and i can continue to invade
and attack these pawns
instead rook a to c8 was my choice
knight to e4 by vinnie
allowing this bishop once again to see
into the position
uh also just stepping out of some
immediate threats here
so knight to e4
knight takes e3 i decided is time to
play
and then knight to b4 so once again i'm
keeping the pressure up on d3 i'm trying
to activate along the c file and once
again vinnie just ignores my threat
entirely comes in with queen to b6 and
goes goes for the act of counter play
and
you can really contrast this with the
last game that was played where
uh white goes
queen e3 rook d3 rook a3 and tries to
defend the c pawn uh compare that with
with how vinny's playing here like he's
he's attacking my b-pawn he's making use
of his active pieces he's attacking my
a-pawn he's going for the act of
counter-play not even blinking against
these threats to the d3 pawn
now because he has made so many mistakes
in the opening he's still gonna be worse
here but practically you'll you can
really see uh how many more chances he
he has in the game right it's very easy
for black to play one bad move here and
then just be worse
um and in fact that that's about to
happen
so in this position i i still don't
fully remember the most accurate way to
play oh i do actually so
queen to b6 is making like three
different threats uh one threat is to
take on a five uh okay really only two
threats white wants to take on a5 white
also wants to play knight to d6
attacking all of my weaknesses and
activating the bishop so it turns out i
have a pretty subtle move that helps
play against both of these ideas which
is bishop to f8 so
concretely that stops the knight from
coming to d6 i just control the square
enough times
and against something like queen to a5 i
can now actually push this queen
all the way back home
and then
consider stuff like like takes on d3 and
while i haven't won a pawn here it turns
out that white's pieces are just a
little bit disjointed on all these
squares right you see this bishop
opposite this rook you see this queen
sort of hanging out on this open file
and this knight just very loosely
defended turns out this was the way to
get an advantage um instead
i chose the move rook to c2 trying to
activate my own pieces
and vinnie came up with this really
strange move rook to c3
so i think this was vinnie playing for
tricks a little bit but it turns out to
not be a horrible move so of course what
was vinnie's idea if i attacked two
pieces at the same time
he had something in mind
yeah this was his idea uh he was hoping
he would do this so he could take both
my rooks and then have this slightly
favorable imbalance in his favor
uh turns out he can also do stuff like
queen to c5 i think which is just sort
of crazy to me but of course i don't
have to fall for this so i play rogue
takes b2
uh but again rook c3 another instance he
doesn't care about his b-pawn he puts
his rook on an active open file and
continues to keep the pressure up
after rook b2 he plays queen to a queen
takes a5
i step back with knight to c6 he goes
queen to b6
and then here i play the move rook to a2
which gives away the last of my
advantage uh at the start of these this
active variation uh it was like minus
two for black um after a couple slight
inaccurate moves so only minus one for
black and after rook to a2 it's actually
white who might be starting to press for
things so i was just getting destroyed
by vinnie in this game he makes one
opening mistake
and then i i slowly but surely give away
my advantage
so all he had to do here was find one
more accurate move and then i think uh
the game definitely would have been
totally up in the air so wait to move
here
and keep the pressure on what can he do
yeah just the simple move knight to c5
and after the game he told me he shied
away from this move because he was
worried about things like e4
and knight d4 which knight d4 is
definitely one of my main intentions so
e4 attacking this rook and i guess
vinnie saw something he didn't like here
it's worth noting as well he used a lot
of time to get to this position so he
might maybe didn't have as much time as
he wanted to to figure out all the
details
but knight to c5 turns out just to be a
very very good move for example if i go
knight d4
takes takes uh something like queen back
to b3 rook over to e2 uh bishop f3 my
pieces are getting bullied uh and white
is is picking up an extra pawn on b7
right now i'm probably going to get some
of this stuff back um and at worst i
think this is a repetition that that
white might want to take otherwise you
know
having these major pieces all working
together can be a little bit scary um
but
you know white is is definitely
surviving and potentially even pushing
for more if he wants
so knight to c5 very very strong move uh
instead vinnie unfortunately blundered
the game immediately with knight e to d6
and i don't know what he thought he saw
i don't know what he was looking at but
of course i can capture these knights in
exchange for my rooks then after queen
to b7 it looks like there are some very
active threats uh happening uh to
black's position here you know can
imagine if i play let's say a bad move
hard to play a bad move here actually
let's say i play knight to b8 then you
know you can imagine like oh bishop to
d5 and oh my goodness all my pieces are
attacked uh but of course these tactics
just aren't working i go knight to d8
gaining a tempo against the queen also
defending my king's side queen comes to
b3 i just adjust the bishop back to e6
and play e4 take on d3 and vinnie lost
the game pretty shortly after this you
know black is just totally winning now
this pawn is way too strong i'm actually
crashing through on the f2 square as
well and i just have more pieces so
that'll do it
but the point of the game isn't
necessarily the result but uh everything
leading up to this big blunder knight to
d6 blunders happened in chess hard to
avoid them but you can really see like
vinnie was taking control over this game
he was just a move or two away from
being very firmly in control and it's
because he went for this active counter
play he didn't curl up into a ball once
once he had some weaknesses
so those were the two big examples i had
of this you know against pratik teak
unfortunately in in that game
specifically uh didn't do a very good
job of putting up the most resistance
vinnie in this game you know made me
calculate my my heart out i was
exhausted after this game
um because just all of all these
variations that he kept coming up with
all these active ideas made my life very
very difficult and i was only saved by
by you know uh random chance when
you know his number came up it was his
time to blunder happens to the best of
us
uh so questions on these two sort of
contrasting games you've sort of seen an
example of each now uh what happened in
critique's game versus what happened in
vinnie's game before i move on to to
game three which is just total chaos
any questions at all we talked about a
lot of different ideas
all right
so let's move on then to
the rematch caleb versus critique and
i'm actually showing these games a
little bit out of order so this game
happened first chronologically but it
didn't fit as well with the theme of the
lecture so that's why you're seeing it
third
um so this petite guy while in round 10
wasn't his best showing
he's a very very scary chess player to
play i've played him three times now and
i've scored one and a half out of three
and that's only because i'm a luck box
um against the other uh national master
in this events uh he also is scoring
very very well i think he's beaten uh
julian i think he's beaten twice
and drawn once no he's drawn twice and
beaten once so he has a positive record
against julian uh not easy to do
uh but in this game i i think we're both
gonna show that's uh
you know nobody in this tournament
really understands chess uh myself
included
so to start with we're gonna see another
carl's badge structure i promised you it
was coming
this is the game so we played i i played
the exchange queen's gambit decline uh
these moves are all very normal just
developing the pieces and of course this
is uh a normal carlsbad this time rather
than with the colors reversed
we get castles knight g to e2 is my idea
so once again keeping in mind my plan of
going f3e4
as well as a minority attack
so black plays rook to e8 i castle
h6 is included
which this is a move i don't yet fully
understand some very very strong players
have started doing this but for like you
know the past 50 years everybody sort of
agreed it was a mistake to play this
move
uh so i don't want to get into that
because i don't understand it people
better than me also don't understand it
so h6 bishop h4 he wanted to include it
fair enough not gonna critique it uh he
goes knight h5 which is a common idea
here uh to try and play a little bit
against how i organize my pieces with
this knight on e2 and also just uh it's
kind of a freeing move just to trade off
these bishops give his pieces some more
space
so i take and he takes and i play queen
to d2 uh and i played queen to d2 here
because i knew this position
uh if we check in the database really
quickly
there should be one game here between
magnus carlson and vladimir kramnik that
continued with knight d7 and magnus made
chess look easy as he sometimes does and
and won that game without too much
difficulty so i was hoping for that
um but of course what's the idea with
with queen to d2 does anybody have any
idea of how i might want to reorganize
my pieces after let's say knight d7 see
if you guys can play like magnus
what's the point of putting your queen
on this slightly weird looking square
we connect the rooks and that's exactly
right we want to play rook a to e1
and
let me just continue playing like
vladimir kramnik uh knight to f8
and our follow-up is just knight to c1
which might not be entirely obvious but
the point now is that we have defended
our e pawn twice
and after knight f6 for example we can
go f3 and once again we've found a way
to organize our forces to play for this
e4 plan so this is what i wanted
now my opponent having played me before
has some idea of the the plans i like to
go for maybe he's seen one or two road
to 2000s on the f3 nimzo where i play f3
e4 every game and try to crush my
opponent
so he took some time at the board and he
played this move f5
so what are you guys thoughts on this
move f5 what's going on here
why f5
put another pepper on e4 yeah another
attacker on e4 and just very concretely
trying to stop after e4 right that's
that's that's the idea he says all right
i know you i know what you're about no
f3 e4 against me
uh of course though if you remember the
first game that i showed uh i was hoping
that white would play f4 in that
position which is basically just f5 uh
with the colors reversed so what is the
downside it's gonna be all the same
downsides as before number one in this
instance the pawn might be weak because
we don't have a strong knight on e4 just
yet
the second rank is also going to be very
very weakened
as well as of course you know things
like this
light square diagonal might also be be
relevant in this case
uh so the question now
is your opponent has played this move f5
very concretely trying to stop you from
playing e4 so
you know this move probably isn't
correct because you've seen the position
before you know hey you know it's not
really great for black to be weakening
the position like this but how can you
try to take advantage here how can you
try to take advantage there's actually a
number of things that you can do
you could switch gears
that's exactly what i did in the game i
went rook a to b1 b4 and decided okay if
you want to uh to stop me from playing
f3 e4 that's fine congratulations you've
done it i have more than one idea in the
position and if i get the minority
attack through if i succeed then you're
going to regret in weakening your second
rank you're going to regret
uh weakening all these light squares in
your position and my my minority attack
is only going to be stronger because of
it
and it turns out that's a perfectly fine
way to play um now there are a number of
other things you can do here i actually
took a lesson with our grand master in
residence josh fidel
who will be teaching right after me by
the way
and he pointed out that very concretely
black is underdeveloped compared to
white our rooks are connected so moves
like knight to f4 are already going to
be tempting with the idea being that
we're just immediately going to come in
and try to do stuff like rook f5 and
make black's life very very difficult so
concretely there are some tactical ways
you can play for the advantage here um
what i did does turn out to be fine um
so i actually start with this move queen
to c2 drawing this rick back to f8 which
depending on who you ask might not be
the best idea rook might actually be
worse than this square
but okay rook f8 and then i go rook ab1
um black comes out now with queen to g5
and this is my first big mistake in the
game i think it just makes sense
continue on with b4 b5 queen g5 not
really going to make a severe enough
threat for the same reasons that i
talked about before if you want to play
f4
i'm happy to allow it
because your pieces are just so
underdeveloped here don't even think
about going for stuff like this
with your king on g8 like you're just
just dead lost already
so this was another joshua doll um
observation why are you worried about f4
black hasn't developed any pieces just
continue with your plan was was he's
what he suggested can also play
something like g3 here just solidifying
and many ways to be better
instead i played the move f4 um and it
turns out after f4
uh this obviously creates a weakness of
my own
uh on e3 and the best way for black to
play now is just to immediately start
targeting this weakness and black is
going to be a lot closer to equal than
he otherwise should be
now in the game pratik went with queen
to g6 the idea being he wants to defend
this pawn twice so he can put this
knight in front of this bishop
and now i'm able to go back to my
initial plan so b4 a6 a4 bishop b6 and
b5 we did it minority attack we're the
best
uh a b a b knight d7 is played and i
continue out now with uh b take c b take
c
and as promised the point of the
minority attack is we've traded off our
pawn minority in order to make a very
severe weakness in black's camp in this
case that weakness being the c6 pawn
and now if i were a good chess player i
would have played great moves targeted
the c6 pawn won the c6 pawn crashed
through taken advantage of all these
weaknesses around my opponent's king and
then won the game
um and we can pretend that that's what
happened but unfortunately there's eight
minutes left in the lecture so you get
to see what i actually did um which
starts with knight a4 which is a great
move
you control the square in front of the
pawn you open up these files to help
target c6
my opponent played rook fc8 and then i
don't know if i played any more good
moves for the rest of the game
so
let's see if you can find one of the
many correct ways here that we can press
for an advantage in particular there's
two ideas that i really really like
i really like the idea of um
okay you want to plant this knight in e5
a noble a noble goal
um
yeah i mean this seems like a reasonable
thing to do the only danger is that if
you give black enough free moves they
might actually be able to do something
uh might be able to do something active
as well
like if you start spending time on
kingdom h1 maybe i'm going to come here
if you come here maybe i'm going to come
here
come here maybe i'm going to come here
and i'm not sure you've improved your
position more than black has improved
his position right all of a sudden i
don't have pressure here
and i'm worried about my king just a
little bit
um so that plan is in theory good but
maybe in practice just a little bit slow
we can play a little bit more actively
make life make black's life a little bit
harder
uh
okay so i like the first part of it rook
b7 um this is a perfectly fine way to
play i think this is the most natural
way to play if you don't
calculate anything concrete
just want to activate this rook and i
don't think we really necessarily even
want to take this knight on c7 uh with
you know the tactical idea we just want
to have a rook on b7 follow it up with
rook f to b1 and eventually we'll go
something like like knight to c5 or
basically depending on what black does
maybe we'll just invade further
maybe we will start to activate this
knight as well uh but we can just
activate our pieces you know there are
all these holes in our opponent's
position so we can activate around them
now i think the absolute best way to
play here is knight to c5 with an idea
you might not expect so knight takes c5
is probably what black should do
otherwise we are going to continue with
something like rook to b7 and give black
some very concrete problems and actually
white's point here is to take back with
the pawn uh and the reason is
you know this plan was great but it
takes like five moves and this plan
takes one move and immediately targets
both weaknesses and black structure so
uh this is always an idea to be on the
lookout for if you can change your
structure to give your your pieces a
better square then this is very often
going to be a a good idea
and in this case i think white is uh
pretty close to winning here like plus
1.5 plus two
numbers like that if you ask a computer
just because it's very very difficult to
keep everything under control and uh
your counter play as black is is not
really going anywhere
instead i chose a bad move in the form
of knight to b6
so my idea was that after takes which is
forced i could play rook takes and
immediately i have some really nice
pressure against this pawn on c6
now the downside is that after this move
bishop to d7 turns out the black's
position is surprisingly tenable uh this
bishop on d7 is doing all the heavy
lifting defending the weakness on c6
defending the weakness on f5 and it's
such a good defender that black can now
start to play actively so i tried knight
to c3 trying to get my second piece in
the game but it turns out concretely i
was not keeping track of my own
weaknesses and after queen to e6 to play
some really awkward moves to keep
everything together i was planning rook
to e1 here
but that turns out to lose tonight to f4
so instead i had to play the very very
awkward rook to f3 now already pratik in
this instance uh played much much better
than in the the first game that i showed
he's not gonna sit back play like rook
a7 to c7 and defend his weaknesses comes
rook a one check of course he does of
course active play always uh going to be
more human uh and in my opinion almost
always better
i played this move knight to b1 which is
probably a mistake i should just admit
okay things are going wrong i need to
play rook to b1 just trade off these
rooks and
reassess try to reorganize
instead i go knight to b1 he continues
playing well knight to f6
i try to improve my king with h3 and
king to h2
critique again playing actively actually
removing a defender from his c6 pawn in
order to try and attack me
um we see h5 in the game
and then here i go knight to c3 trying
to activate uh and hope against hope to
get my pieces in the game
uh but this move actually just loses by
force already so things have gone so
wrong for white black has played well
enough activating all the pieces not
meekly defending the weakness that there
is a winning tactic in the form of
knight to g4 check just turns out this
move is
very very difficult to meet if ticks
then takes this active rook on the first
rank combined with an active queen
coming to age six is is just going to be
death
just death for white
so after knight to c3 this was actually
missed he played h4
and the game is going to continue here
pratik is coming after me but i'm just
in time to trade off some pieces and get
a hold of the position once again
from here on out i play pretty okay
right up until the moment where after a3
i go bishop e2
blundering rook takes e3
so
just like vinnie in the last game my
number was up it was my time to blunder
um these things do happen
but then uh unlike vinnie i actually
could still save the game i just had to
play rick takes e3 and it turns out that
this queen takes f4 move is not so bad
for me i may be down some pawns but
black structure is very very bad as is
this bishop and concretely black is is
not even gonna be much better in this
position you'd love to play f4 but there
are some serious problems with that as
as we'll see
so missed my chance instead i played
knight d3
and things continued to devolve from
here white's now down two pawns and
should just be losing
but because i'm a dirty swindler the
game continued
um g5 and knight g6 gets rid of my
strong night and things start to look
pretty hopeless
but i invaded with the queen
we saw some dancing checks
and eventually pratik blunders with this
move bishop to e6 maybe got a little bit
frustrated with all these checks which
does allow me to pick up one pawn
and then from here i go queen to c1 and
it turns out this is a very very tough
position for black to actually win with
this queen on c1
there are always going to be very
serious problems with pushing the g pawn
forward and maybe white should actually
be holding here
now in the game things continued to
devolve i'm going to skip a little bit
ahead because it was a long long game
and we got to a position like this so
black it did achieve this move g4 and
then from here on out i go full on
swindle mode so the game continued with
g3
i checked block bishop d7
queen g5 queen f1 king f6
i bring this bishop back to d3 targeting
the f5 pawn
and then we'll see if you guys can uh
can swindle with the best of them to end
out the lecture here so pratik played
queen e3 double question mark
what are you going to do
to uh to swindle your half point
what can you do it looks hopeless black
is black is gonna go here and then here
and then you're in trouble
black is also going to go here and then
you're in trouble so if you play like
queen e2 or something
you lose some pawns things things don't
go well oh i see okay
you can play
bishop takes uh five great move to start
so
in time pressure your opponent blundered
the stalemate trick
and then if we were both a thousand
points lower rated he would take on f5
and then i would resign
um but of course rather than resign i
would take on f5 back
and i would then checkmate my opponent's
king
um
maybe or maybe i would just check him
forever
or checkmate and then you take me
and you are
putting me into stalemate with a draw
so that's my big trap but of course you
know
critique sees me play bishop f5 like he
knows what's up he knows what's up right
so he comes up with this nice move queen
to f2 to keep the game going
and then i do my best my best acting i
say ah
darn you saw my trick and i play bishop
back to d3
and very quickly critique takes on f1
and i take on f1 and he plays king f5
and now
my position seems hopeless right my
opponent is going to go here and then
here and then here and then i'm in in
big trouble
so what's the deal what's the deal is it
actually hopeless
is it actually hopeless here
should i throw in the towel resign the
game
of course not but why not what's my
trick
what's my trick any sam shanklin fans in
the chat this isn't quite what sam
shanklin did but it's close
so sam shanklin famous for resigning in
a drawn position
very similar to this
whipster says bishop c4 but
unfortunately i i do have a legal king
move now so black could just take this
also that would give me a legal pawn
move as well
the bishop should be able to get to f3
and then the king can run over to d1
yeah you can't you can do this but
you're not going to be holding this game
you're not going to be holding this this
goes here this goes here this goes here
my king goes here
and then you're in trouble
so of course
we go bishop b5
bishop c6
and bishop takes d5
and it turns out that this end game is a
draw uh which you might not expect
um so of course the first idea is that
you can never attack g2 a second time or
else it's still mate
and if you try to be very very clever
and sacrifice your bishop for one of my
pawns
and go king f3
then i have to go king g1
you go g2
but unfortunately for you my h3 pawn
actually works in my favor here and
after king h2
king f2
i am stalemated thanks to my buddy on h3
and this is actually how the game ended
so after after all that after all those
blunders after all that uh controversy
game ends by by stalemate so useful to
know some of these end game fortresses
not that useful but in this case it came
to my rescue so
what was the point of it all well this
last game was a little bit more chaotic
but once again you see that when you
make a bunch of weaknesses in your
position you know one way or the other
it it sometimes happens you shouldn't
just curl up in defense you need to find
active play you got to activate your
pieces fight back against the opponent
and then you're going to have a lot of
chances
as we saw in this game to to end up end
up winning
with that i think i'm a little bit over
time so thank you all so much for
joining me here tonight uh coming up
next momentarily will be grand master
josh fedele uh who is leaving soon he
only has
uh one more lecture i think on youtube
here so make sure you stick around while
we still got josh and it'll be it'll be
a good time
all right so as always thank you all so
much for watching my name is caleb denby
this has been the road to 2000 and i
will see you next week
[Music]
you